breaking news guys this is serious why
Taps revealed that both the US women and
UK women plan to frame tape these
documents are actually crazy so guys two
of the girls who claim to have been
victims to take brothers were caught
discussing how to make fools of
themselves before the police descended
but also how they were determining how
to disguise themselves so not to be
recognized after the law enforcement
raid it says in civil war attacks the
two young women who claim to have been
victims of the Tate Brothers shared
secrets and advice to help them in their
chosen careers after finding themselves
at the center of a scandal of major
propositions the two were caught trying
to figure out how to disguise themselves
okay they were holding them look at
there's a there's a fence there they
there's they're they're stuck he
recognized by fans on adult websites
another conversation held by the young
women from USA with her mother the
victim to take Brothers is confronted by
the woman who accused her of setting the
authorities on Via so guys this is
footage of the transcripts we'll go
through so I basically said you are a
good actress true and says just play it
cool this is dealing with the police
like you don't know play you are a good
actress true
I practiced Perfecto question just play
it cool got it like you don't know
anything
[Music]
play dumb
I'm going to pull some tears out
huh
and play dumb good advice thank you babe
this is very interesting so far two days
before the first race there's no contact
okay but okay April 2022 okay all right
a dumb another one says I'm good
we are so good though we need a [__]
Oscar
let's go who uses a question mark as a
tea it's kind of sus let's
or is that like it's an apostrophe
oh
let's just go play it cool and change my
name so I will not start with a with a
LOL got it and then yeah I told you to
be like saying a nice message and that
we were hurt or [__] like that and that
we do love them but just don't like the
situation it's hard to believe that all
of this could be over some dumb broads
who just want some clout and money
like there's no like that's
crazy going to pull some tears this is
then pretended to the police that
they're victims this is massive the fact
that these guys are still behind bars
conviction to doing stuff like this is
absolutely crazy let's just go play it
cool and change my name so it will not
say we were doing that and then someone
says LOL got it these are some of the
stuff they were saying so so but you
know to say that we don't like the
situation and then yeah go ahead early
on
so they will not think we are really
against them you know yeah that's smart
play the victim I mean we are but like
yeah act like we still love them and
stuff I mean we are
okay play the victim I mean we are but
like so then they say I mean we are
and then the person says hahaha I mean
we are question mark
wait what what this is Sassy play the
victim I mean yeah act like we still
love them and stuff hahaha
you know this guy's laugh is goated
okay tomorrow we should wear makeup and
sunglasses so nobody really notices what
we look like or who we are right there
yeah I guess LOL
we're writing a movie tomorrow we should
wear makeup but sunglasses so nobody
really notices what we look like or who
we are yeah I guess laugh out loud we
are writing a movie they wanted to
become famous in this next bit they're
saying for sure we have to make a movie
saying let's email Netflix ASAP or
Amazon Prime they wanted some sort of
documentary made about them being fake
victims which is absolutely sick so
these two have been proven not to be
victims the rest of these transcripts
kind of get a bit sensitive I'm gonna
put it over assuming assuming this stuff
is true it's really a shame that the
Tate brothers or whoever hired these
girls for whatever the role were were
it's really a shame that they were
fooled by them like that's pretty
astonishing you know say it's very very
adamant that he understands people best
and he knows what's going on and he's in
control and if this is true that means
that there were snakes in his house and
he didn't know can't keep those low
quality women around right well the fact
is if these girls are you know I mean
they look cheap frankly so how do you
know
um just by some of the outfits that they
were wearing that they looked kind of
like these girls who we don't know if
those are the same girls that were in
the video I don't know what those girls
are I mean if these are webcam girls you
know they have there's something wrong
with the head so you know you have
you're trusting these people who are
like emotionally incapable to begin with
frankly they have Dan they're damaged
and then you trust them with your life
and look at what they're what they're
doing if this is true I'm sure Andrew's
gonna be married he's gonna have his one
girl with him after this he's making
he's making roster Cuts you guys did not
find one but it's hard enough to find
one good one find one good one and stick
with her and and and have her back and
she'll have yours I'm sure this is this
is what happens when the Harem gets too
big yeah it's hard to believe he's still
locked up over the this [__] well we
don't know if it's over this [__]
because this is
even coming out it has anything come out
because you know I'm not on the I don't
have my finger on the pulse of Andrew
tells in this case I mean two months you
think they would have been able to find
something to say like like proof of
something that he's a trafficker it's
funny because even when they use like
the PHD course and stuff for example
they purposely don't include the parts
where he's like and if you're out with
the girl and she wants to go home you
don't ask twice you send her home in an
Uber and you don't you don't say
anything else that's it like that's good
advice like you don't want to be seeming
desperate with these girls you know he's
not saying like and then if she wants to
go home now is when you grab her and you
throw her in the car and you take her to
your house this is the best time like no
man you're being like a good guy and
Uber them home they love that [__] I
have been on dates with men who were
just gross and I was like I want to go
home now and they were like okay
absolutely aggressive gross men they're
like okay because they just don't want
to be bothered with a girl that doesn't
want to be there get her out of here
boom take me home that was it nice and
easy and he's teaching men to also do
more polite things like you know be a
gentleman take care of the check keep
her safe
so whatever like the funniest thing is
like they act like they're just it's
it's hard for them to get girls around
them like them having multiple
girlfriends that are beautiful and loyal
is like a crazy thought when you're that
high status of a guy yeah like it's
highly successful Rich good looking
young like they're only mid-30s good
shape I mean they have when the girls
ask for like you know when the fat girl
puts in her Tinder bio what she wants
it's like you know basically everything
these guys are but then that's toxic
masculinity now makes no sense it needs
to be six feet he needs to make six
figures he needs to be ripped and what
do you need to do you're fat thanks for
watching Everybody let me fix my hair
you want to see some of the new girls
that have been that have been sliding in
oh yeah there's more I want to thank
everybody out there for stop sending me
pictures of uh body parts that was
really weird when that was happening
that hasn't happened in a while and I'm
grateful all right who who are these
broads let's see she's laying on her
back making kissy face at you she's a
hoe nice girls don't do that she's a
very nice looking girl you're tripping
this is like nothing compared to what's
typically on people's instruments no but
laying on the bed making kissy faces
like that yeah she sends that she has
that video saved and she sends it to
every guy it's on her story she is
gorgeous wow good for her good for you
if she's real
um why can't you just be happy for me
for once this is crazy yeah I'm never
happy for you it's so true I'm the worst
it's a good job it's my job to protect
you yeah I do respond to like all of my
DMs so make sure to go follow me on
Instagram at sunnyfast like And
subscribe and I'll see you later join me
on Twitter
[Music]
spread the riding on the wall won't last
long yeah the feelings
[Music]